here at google we continue to see a lot
of developers building their apis on top
of microservices
so in this example we've deployed a
weather api on cloudrun
it's made up of four different services
this is great for you as an api provider
because it gives you a lot of
flexibility around how you deploy and
how you scale these services
but as an api consumer you don't want to
keep track of which service is
responsible for which
piece of the api you just want one
interface that you can call to access
all the capabilities provided by this
api so let's take a look at how google
cloud's api gateway can help you
combine all these services into one easy
to use api
to get started we'll need an open api
specification that defines each of the
resources in our api
next we'll add instructions to tell the
api gateway where to route the request
for each of those resources
finally we'll want to secure our api so
we'll configure a security definition
that requires all incoming calls to
provide
a valid api key once we have our open
api specification we're ready to create
our api gateway
first we'll specify the display name and
give our api a unique identifier
next we'll define the api's initial
configuration by uploading our open api
file
we'll then give our configuration a
display name and we'll configure the
service account that will be used to
call our backend services
finally we're ready to deploy our api
configuration to a new gateway
in this case that gateway will run in
the u.s central region
once we hit create after a few minutes
our gateway will be ready
to start accepting incoming api requests
because we've secured our api we'll need
valid credentials in this case we've
elected to use api keys as our security
mechanism
we can get an api key for our api in the
apis and services section of the google
cloud console
once we have our key we can make an api
call from the command line using curl
if we try to access our api without
providing a key the call will be
rejected by the gateway
once we add our key to the request the
gateway then allows our call to go
through successfully
that was just a quick preview of how you
can use the new api gateway to create
and secure your apis